ozark's story of money laundering drug
dealing
and cartel violence is a tense thrill
ride it can be a little hard to keep
track of every twist the show takes so
we're here to help you keep the birds
many dirty deeds
straight with this timeline of the whole
show
back in 2007 marty bird begins his
career as a financial advisor
alongside his friend bruce the duo is
approached by a member of the navarro
drug cartel named dell
who needs a money launderer marty
initially refuses to work with him but
his wife wendy struggling to rejoin the
workforce after giving birth to their
second child
once in marty agrees the arrangement
dell kills his previous accountant in
front of them
claiming that he had been skimming
profits as well as snitching to an fbi
agent named roy petty 10 years later
marty's life is disrupted when an
unhappy wendy embarks on an affair
dell confronts marty and bruce about
bruce skimming profits from the cartel
dell has bruce and all others involved
killed desperate to save himself and his
family
marty offers to move to the ozarks in
missouri where he will launder an
obscene amount of money
for the cartel over the next five years
dell agrees now i want you to take my
seven million
nine hundred and seventy three thousand
with you to missouri
and clean it dell gives marty several
days to recoup the money his associates
stole and complete his move
wendy's lover gary convinces her that
she needs to grab what money she can
and leave marty before she can however
the cartel has gary killed
their message is clear wendy needs to
stick with her family or else
the birds sell their chicago home and
move to the ozarks the landmarks a local
family sneak into their hotel room and
steal a portion of the 8 million dollars
the drug cartel gave them to launder
marty confronts the langmores in an
abandoned outhouse and lays out the
whole situation for them
particularly the consequences the
interaction leads to the hiring of ruth
langmore for various dirty deeds
marty intends to use lickety-splits a
local strip club as a money-laundering
front
he pays ruth to break into a safe at the
club and seal the deed to the
establishment
ruth gets herself hired by the club and
marty makes her manager when he gains
control
after the bodies of marty's former
associates are discovered
fbi agent roy petty arrives in the
ozarks wendy leads an exhausting search
for a family home
with a bumbling real estate agent named
sam eventually they find a beautiful
lakefront house to rent however the
reason they can afford it
is because it comes with an interesting
stipulation the owner buddy wishes to
remain in the house
his intention is to live in the basement
for another year while he dies from
heart disease wendy agrees to the
unusual arrangement
who is that
that is buddy dyker bobby the previous
owner of lickety splits is revealed to
be part of a separate money laundering
operation for jacob and darlene snell
a drug-dealing couple who specialize in
heroin for his failure
darlene injects bobby with a lethal dose
of heroin giving the corrupt police
chief reason to sweep the death under
the rug
jacob informs marty of the arrangement
he had with bobby and attempt to
convince him to take up bobby's old job
marty refuses and tensions begin to rise
roy hires ruth's uncle russ as a fishing
guide the relationship turns intimates
and roy uses a situation to gain
leverage
marty continues his hunt for businesses
to launder money through
he meets jason a pastor who delivers his
sermons on the water
looking to funnel cash through a
construction project marty offers mason
funding to build a church
the snails inform him that they use
those lake sermons to distribute their
product
and that he needs to back off or else
they might hurt mason's pregnant wife
grace and now you have destroyed
our very means of distribution mason is
informed
that the snails and marty's are legal
intentions he has a crisis of conscience
in which he burns down the framework for
the new church
and stops delivering his sermons on the
water this brings the snell's drug
operations to a complete halt
in order to keep the snails from killing
him marty gives them
seven hundred thousand dollars of the
cartel's money
mason refuses to return to preaching
despite pressure from the snails who
decide to take revenge
mason arrives home one day to find a
newborn baby on his porch
and his wife nowhere to be found in
order to recoup the 700
000 of cartel money they lost wendy
convinces sam to transfer his mother's
900 000
portfolio into the birds accounts they
use the money to launder the rest of the
cartel's cash just before the deadline
this brings no relief however the cartel
quickly delivers another 50 million
dollars in cash that marty must find a
way to launder
sam's mother dies and he requests access
to her funds in order to pay for her
funeral expenses
the birds end up buying the funeral home
ruth finds out that her uncle plans to
kill marty and subsequently kills her
uncle to stop him the death is ruled in
accidental electrocution which doesn't
sit well with russ's son
wyatt marty arranges new identities for
his family so they can skip town
they are stopped by a cartel member
named garcia but the family is able to
escape when buddy holds the man at
gunpoint and ultimately kills him
drawn by these events dell travels to
the ozarks and tortures marty for
information
on what happened to garcia frantically
marty pieces together a plan
he proposes a casino built on the
snail's lands the cartel will distribute
the snail's heroin
and both operations could have their
money laundered by marty the snails
and dell agree to these terms as they
part ways adele refers to his new
partners as rednecks
a hot-headed darlene snell pulls out a
shotgun and fires directly into dell's
face
you just cannot do that i want to buy
that talk you know that
man was guest the cartel's attorney an
imposing woman named helen pierce
arrives in the ozarks
helen informs the involved parties that
reparations for dell's death are needed
to protect his wife
jacob kills ash their right-hand man
this place saves the cartel but darlene
is enraged by the decision
to her the obedient ash was like the sun
she never had as legislation for the
casino slowly moves forward
another chess piece comes into play
ruth's father cade is released from
prison
the man had already been pulling strings
from his cell and now he wants all of
marty's money
ruth tries to convince him that there is
a way to make money from the birds that
isn't so reckless when they stop at a
diner
kade robs the place he climbs back into
the car with his loot looks at his
daughter
and tells her that she will help him
steal marty's money and then bird has
got a million bucks to toss around
there's more that came from and you're
gonna find it
the kansas city mafia rattles the cages
of local senators by threatening their
businesses
weakening their support for the casino
as it turns out buddy has a pass with
the mob's leader frank cosgrove this
connection allows marty to meet with
frank and find common ground
they agree that the casino will be
unionised allowing the casino bill to
move forward
in the meantime trouble brews at the
blue cat a diner marty owns but leaves
in the hands of manager rachel the
previous owner
having discovered marty's money
laundering she steals a chunk of cartel
money goes on a bender
and wrecks her car roy capitalizes on
the situation
turning her into an informant by feeding
her drugs and marching her right back to
the blue cat
wyatt is not convinced his father's
death was an accident he continues to
dig for the truth
while kade uses the unraveling situation
as leverage over ruth
ready to burst from anxiety ruth
confides in rachel
who reports what she knows back to roy
the information allows roy to get
warrants to search the properties of
everyone involved
good morning roy arranges a meeting with
ruth in which he threatens to throw her
to the cartel unless she becomes his
informant
after learning of the meeting helen has
ruth brutally interrogated in order to
test her loyalty
after a lengthy waterboarding session
she proves trustworthy
roy begins searching bird's businesses
for dirt and sets his sights on the
snail's property
in order to avoid fbi detection helen
orders them to burn their poppy fields
they refuse the revelation of a drug
operation on the land would ruin
everything
so the birds decide to act wendy uses
darlene's desire for children as a
distraction
she offers to meet and discuss how to
help them adopt a child meanwhile buddy
sneaks onto the property and burns their
poppy fields
the act of vandalism appears to
rejuvenate the frail dying man
but on their drive home he passes away
in the passenger seat next to wendy
marty finds out that rachel is working
with roy as an informant
and uses her to feed the fbi false
information the fbi doesn't find any
evidence of a drug operation on the
snell's property but they do discover
human remains in the ashes of the burned
field
this discovery gives mason hope which he
sorely needs he has been reduced to
preaching on the street
which results in the state taking away
custody of his son
zeke desperate mason kidnaps wendy
demanding the return of his son
marty uses his political connections to
get zeke out of state custody
and takes him to mason things go awry
however and marty ends up killing mason
marty and wendy cremate mason's body and
keep the baby a story is concocted
painting a grief stricken mason as
having abandoned his child
once roy gets everything he needs from
rachel he cuts off her supply of drugs
she buys her own off the street and ends
up overdosing
still angry about the burning of their
poppy fields darlene still retaliates
against a cartel by spiking their
heroine with fintanil the cartel
responds with an attack on the snails
that injures jacob
he displays an awareness that his wife's
temper is disrupting every facet of
their operation
he moves to repair his relationships
with both the cartel and marty
the fbi is closing in and marty moves
against roy a gathering of information
reveals that roy's mother is a drug
addict
and a cartel member is sent to supply
her with drugs this relapse results in
roy abandoning his work to go home
and take care of his mother meanwhile
the bird family unit is disrupted when
their daughter charlotte hires a lawyer
to have herself emancipated
i've made up my mind
i won out jacob snell is informed that
all legal avenues to take his land are
available to the birds they give him the
opportunity to back off and allow
operations to move along
jacob knows that darlene is wildly
volatile and would have no part in any
of this
on a morning walk through the woods he
slowly works up the courage to kill his
wife
just as he walks up to stab her however
he collapses at her feet
darlene had already poisoned his coffee
the snell patriarch dies in her arms
while she whispers her love to him
marty attends a gathering of the gaming
commission a stipulation is made to deny
any union presence once a casino is
operational
marty agrees to the arrangement despite
it going against the deal he made with
the kansas city mafia the casino's
construction has moved through the
appropriate legal channels
darlene uses intimidation to get baby
zeke from the birds and claim him as her
own
roy returns to the ozarks and is
confronted by cade who is desperate to
become an informant to avoid going back
to prison
their interaction ends with cade
murdering roy with a bait box
and sinking his body in the river
frantic he returns home and attempts to
blackmail ruth for money to skip town
instead of folding ruth walks up to
wyatt and tells him she killed his
father
when he realizes that cade needs to be
removed from the equation
and has a cartel member kill him frank
cuz grove lets marty know that the mafia
is displeased with him by bombing his
office
the casino opens and day-to-day
operations begin charlotte decides to
remain with her family but convinces her
parents to go to couples therapy
marty pays a therapist to take his side
embroiled in an intense war with another
cartel
navarro himself reaches out to wendy she
lays out a plan to move his money into
legitimate channels ensuring his
family's future
marty sees the move as too big of a risk
and pushes back after learning the truth
of his father's death
wyatt leaves his family home and is
eventually arrested for squatting in
people's houses
darlene bails him out and offers him
work just as the bird family dynamic is
beginning to settle
wendy's brother ben arrives after being
fired from his job as a substitute
teacher
frank cosgrove's son mills around the
casino as a mafia presence
and is disrespectful of ruth's authority
in response to his intimidation
ruth throws him off the second story of
a riverboat come get yourself
wendy and marty disagree on what
direction to take their business wendy
wants to expand while marty wants to be
more cautious
purchasing another local casino results
in the birds playing mind games with a
couple who owns it
marty believes taking on another casino
isn't a necessary risk and talks her
husband into declining the deal
meanwhile wendy's ambition aligns with
navarros she wants to expand
and steers a wife towards selling the
casino while this is going on
wyatt and darlene become uncomfortably
close alerted by income discrepancies
the fbi begin auditing the bird's
businesses
leading the audit is fbi agent maya
miller who offers marty a way out with
little jail time
marty is then kidnapped and taken to
mexico where he was tortured for days
davaro is testing the entire crew
to see if they could continue operating
without marty as well as attempting to
divide the truth of marty's character
a drug cartel war spills into the ozark
area and frank jr's men are killed he
believes that his ruth's fault and
assaults are outside the casinos so
badly
that she is hospitalized marty convinces
navarro that he can turn maya miller and
help him regain control of a frozen
account
and moreover that he is essential to the
entire ozarks operation
meanwhile ben's bipolar disorder begins
to disrupt everything when he goes off
his medication
he explodes after learning about the
family's involvement with the cartel
helen makes it clear he has to be kept
under control
and the pain of cartel retaliation
helen's daughter is also visiting her in
the ozarks
and helen makes it clear that no one is
to inform her of the truth
after an argument in therapy reveals
their cartel involvement to their
therapist
wendy and marty are blackmailed out of a
large sum of money the therapist however
is foolish spending the sum so lavishly
that she draws attention
helen notices and deals with it in her
own way the therapist vanishes
i may have undervalued my services
i'll make sure you're taken care of an
outburst at a charity event forces a
birds to have ben committed to a mental
hospital
darlene uses her connections to get ben
released he drives straight to helen's
house and tells her daughter the truth
about everything
marty decides not to retaliate against
the mafia for ruth's savage beating
in response darlene drives roots to
mafia territory where she shoots frank
jr in the groin
darlene then brings frank senior in on
her own operation ruth joins her cousin
wyatt at the snell farm
seemingly boys to take over drug
operations together and enraged helen
moves to cut the birds out
as well as assassinate ben wendy tries
to get ben to safety but he refuses to
listen
desperate wendy leaves him at a
restaurant and informs a car tell us his
location
the sacrifice does not go unnoticed
navarro brings both wendy and marty down
to mexico and shoots helen upon their
arrival the stunned birds don't even get
a chance to wipe away the blood before
the drug lord pulls them in for a big
hug
celebrating what he sees as a beginning
of a wonderful new phase
in their collaboration today is the
beginning
[Music]
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you